des porcelaines qui teinte
c'est vraiment comme une cloche un son
pur ce sont isabelle l'a appris au fil
des années c'est grâce à lui qu'elle
peut maintenant qualifié une belle
porcelaine et savoir comment la
travailler pour la rendre unique
c'est une passion en tant qu'objet
recherche du bel objet et puis c'est
aussi une passion en tant que quart
faire vivre de donner de donner une
deuxième vie parce que l'objet existe en
tant que lui-même même une assiette
lambda il existe en tant qu elle même
mais delà de la décorer d'essayer de la
décorer d'en donner juste la
quintessence d'en faire quelque chose de
d'essayer d'en faire quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
une passion commencé par hasard en 1989
à leurs salariés dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique
isabelle suit des cours de peinture sur
porcelaine comme loisir un loisir qui
deviendra son métier six ans plus tard
assiettes tasses décoration elle peint à
la main chacun de ces objets une fois
qu'on a va passer le fait le dessin
c'est bon la préparation des couleurs
l'application de la couleur soit à la
plume pour un travail très fin de
précision soit au pinceau
l'objet est ensuite mis dans un four à 8
150 degrés pour fixer la couleur sur la
porcelaine la cuisson peut être répétée
trois ou quatre fois selon la peinture
et le motif un travail créatif de
patience et de précision
il faut aimer le support je pense que
c'est très important d'aimer le support
et il faut vraiment se rendre compte que
ça c'est un travail d'exigence
persévérance exigences minutie pour
pour avancer une exigence que transmet
isabelle en tant que professeur chaque
semaine à ses élèves un savoir-faire de
tradition née au 9e siècle avant
jésus-christ aujourd'hui plusieurs
formations existent pour continuer à
faire vivre cet art ancestral